українсько-російський гордон пункт
пропуску сан текка
у чернілівський області траншею як на
лінії фронту та майже двометровий parkan
з приміткою для укриття цивільних осей
ці прибувають пункті пропуску стіна на
кордоні символічно для нинішніх 100
сумки між українами це росію так
званий європейський вал проект на кілька
сот миль uni в євро за господарі виду
державу вівці ому я поважаючому і захищаємо
у демократичного світла у team поки не
відразу дрібниці зможе parkan це просто
танку віру ви з правдивих і сором і видно
під у Росії але ubooly кому випуску з так
допоможе персоналу
про кордонного педро звуть правда час
стр і молодий і під панель 320
мільйонів євро на проект захисту снасті на
біля ставка шпильках рокки в c гранти
європейського союзу на область що ваня
кордон вмієш україну та росію під на
як трести сумніваюсь а що це мега
проект буде ефективним то ще ми за
різну чому власне або чим у того
яхті та простіше поверталася 2 ст вони
ракети самих форуму про
про далі дещо було бешикташа
ви курс стане я думаю що все таки
вкладу вкладання хороший в 1 канал та
мене в модернізацію української армії
реалізацію проекту європейський у лобі не
зможуть завершить і до 2018 руку-то
найбільша проблема нині з контроль
одягли антиукраїнську російську
кордону укпування сепаратистам і ви
вирішить її і пуки more але нам а гаїті нас
зустрічах у мінську